[موسيقى]
سباق مع الزمن ومراجعات اللحظات الاخيره
ينهمك المخرج والممثلون والمساعدون
لالتقاط المشاهد الاخيره
ارسال ام الياسمين الذي يعرض في رمضان
الحالي
[موسيقى]
انه فلسطين قادره بكوادرها الفنيه من
مصورين وممثلين وكتاب ومخرجين على انتاج
دراما فلسطينيه منافسه
يعني توازي الاعمال العربيه مسلسل ام
الياسمين يعكس الى حد بعيد الحياه
النابلسيه قبل 100 عام تقريبا
وتحديدا السنوات التي اعقبت الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب المدينه
وبالتزامن مع ثوره البراق التي اشعلها
الفلسطينيون ضد الاستعمار الانجليزي
المسلسل يتحدث عنك وعني قاعدين عيله من كل
انواع من اعمار كل حدث العيله بخصه شخص في
المسلسل فهذا اسس فعلا لانه احنا نكون
محاطين بهذا الجمهور الرائع اللي بلش
يعطينا ثمارنا
بلكنه النابلسيه خالصه وبلباس النابلسي
تقليدي يحاول المسلسل معالجه قضايا
اجتماعيه وسياسيه وادبيه سيطرت على الحياه
هنا اضافه الى بعض الابتسامات التي ترسمها
شخصيات المسلسل المختلفه
الله فيك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات